As an example, the simplest connector I can think of is a procedure call and
return. This is a pair of messages. The first one you're calling some method,
and second you're getting every turn value passed back.
This is an asymmetric relationship, okay, that is the caller,
okay? One of the two roles for the, for the connector is caller and the other's
callee. The caller waits, once he's issued the call, for the callee to re,
return. Okay? It's a synchronous relationship because the caller blocks or.
Stops any further computation. The connector also allows for
the passing of information in terms of typed parameters and
the second message may include a return value, also a typed value.